hey Greg knuckles here or string theory
calm and jth strength calm and this is
Oswald the official mascot of string
theory
hi guys anyways today what we are
talking about is mental limits and the
effect of the size of your pond and how
it can affect your long-term strength
progress and potential so the size of
your pond where this concept comes from
is goldfish when you get one and put one
in a little bowl they'll only grow buts
so big but then if you put them in a
pond they get larger if you put them in
the ocean assuming they can tolerate
both freshwater and saltwater that's
irrelevant they get bigger yet
essentially the size of their
environment dictates their potential for
growth and I feel like this concept can
be applied very well to a gym and
training setting as well and to
illustrate I just want to give just want
to give you guys some background about
my history in powerlifting I started
lifting weights not competitively when I
was about 14 years old I started
training for what Oswald it's okay I
started training for football and
basketball just to get bigger stronger
more explosive and then when I realized
the strength training program at my high
school wasn't worth much I sought out
professional help when I was fifteen my
next-door neighbor actually levan
Clement he was the manager at a gym in
town and he kind of took me under his
wing and he said he'd teach me about
lifting weights I really knew
effectively nothing at the time
and as luck would have it
Travis mash was training at the gym at
the time and at the time he was the best
power lifter in the world back in those
days raw powerlifting wasn't really a
thing so he competed in gear but his
best raw lifts were an 805 squat 550
bench and 804 deadlift and the squat is
actually quite low because no one
competed role so no one cared about
their max rahl lives so he just squatted
805 one day for the fun of it
but he had done I think 765 for a set of
5 before so in reality his raw squat was
in the mid to high eights so anyway he
was just ungodly strong I'd see him
bench in the fives some front squat six
thirty
Ross squat in the sevens nonchalantly
just crazy strong guy and then levan the
guy who got me into lifting he was a 500
525 bench I believe and he squatted and
I'd lifted in the sixes and then there
was me and I was the weakest of the crew
by far and except for Seth who he's a
freak in his own right at the time he
weighed about 150 and he was always
within 10 or 20 pounds of me on every
lift and I was like 180 190 anyway so
all said and told I was by far the least
impressive lifter in that group and the
thing was I thought I was weak like I I
did not realize that I was a good lifter
until I actually did a meet and just out
of the blue broke all of the national
records that was that was the kind of
the first tip-off I got that I was
actually good at lifting weights because
well based on the context and what I saw
every day I thought that I was not so
good at it
but anyway so training with those guys
day in and day out in my first 910
months training with them my first meet
which I entered about a week after I
started training at that gym I squatted
385 benched I think to 80 to 85 and dead
lifted for 15 for 25 or so at a body
weight around 170 175 so that was in
March and by January I competed in the
first royal unity meet and as a light
220 I think I weighed in at 213 I
squatted 521 benched 365 and dead lifted
551 I believe stood up with 550 on squat
got caught on depth and pulled 583 twice
on deadlift but got called for hitching
so anyway that was that was about nine
months of progress training consistently
with those guys and again even when I
hit those numbers I was still by far the
worst lifter in that group that I
trained with and then in another two
months so by March of that year I'd
squatted a convincingly deep 550 I
benched 405 and I dead lifted six oh
five or six oh five 600 even one of
those two anyways so that's my first
nine months of powerlifting very soon
thereafter I got a pretty serious back
injury and had to take some time off for
that when I came back to the gym
obviously I'd been out of it so I was
quite a bit weaker started training hard
similarly to how I was before except by
that time the crew had split up Travis
had taken a job in Chicago
lavance he was still at the gym but his
personal training business had taken off
so he wasn't free to Train as often Seth
I think I think during those nine months
Seth may have been unemployed or working
second shift or some
either way he got another job so he
wasn't there to train anymore so
basically that whole crew split up so in
a rapid reversal of fortune I went from
being the weakest person in that group
of lifters to the strongest person in
the gym at any given point in time the
vast majority of the time and really
that that was very very bad for me over
the next three years training some at
that gym but without the old crew
training at a few other gyms I was
almost always the strongest person in
the gym and what would happen is I get
back near my old members um squad around
five benching in the mid threes pulling
in the mid fives I get I get back to
those numbers and I just wanted to be
able to get any stronger like
occasionally I would just take time off
because I lost motivation sometimes I
get another small injury or that old
back injury would flare back up but for
whatever reason I didn't get any
stronger for about three years largely
because I wasn't seeing stronger people
do lifting much heavier weights than I
was week in and week out anymore like I
had previously been used to so at the
end of those three years I ended up
taking about nine months completely off
training and so I started back over in
January of 2011 basically at ground zero
like I said having that lifted for a
solid nine months and from January of
that year to June July of that year I
basically repeated the old pattern again
I got back to a low five squat I think I
benched 375 ish pulled I think 575 and
my numbers just plateaued and they
stayed there for three or four months I
started losing motivation started
thinking here we go again
I
I had in my mind that that was all I was
capable of just because that that's
where I've been stalled for so long and
I simply never saw anyone doing more
than that I really thought that that was
just what my potential was and I just
wasn't going to be able to get any
stronger than that but then I had an
idea I realized back in the day when I
first started weights just never scared
me because you know if I was going for a
squat PR of 500 that was lavance last
warm-up set that was Travis's first
warm-up set just to be a dick to us he
would his first warm-up set four squats
would usually be 495 and his first
warm-up set for deadlifts would usually
be 585 just to make the rest of us feel
bad and so yeah I weights they they just
didn't get in my head because I always
saw them on the bar and when I saw
people lifting weights that were my
maxes they didn't make it look hard it
was it was just a very casual thing for
them to do so what I started doing is
every morning and every night I had
three ed cone videos that I always
watched because I was a 220 at the time
and he is the greatest of all time at
220 so there was a video of him
squatting 875 and just a belt and I
think he may have had a suit on with the
straps down but suits back in the day
didn't give much Gary over especially
with straps down so for all intents and
purposes that's a 860 Ross squat just
made it look like a joke straight down
straight back up then scheen 550 for a
double and deadlifting 903 and I had all
three of those videos pulled up in my
browser at all times and every morning
before class I'd watched them and every
night before I went to bed I watched
them it wasn't a replacement for seeing
it in person because it's just an
entirely different thing but it did get
me used to seeing those weights on the
bar and here's someone my size you know
squatting 300 more pounds than I am in
deadlifting 300 more pounds than I am
benching 175 pounds more than I was and
just absolutely destroying it and that
kind of flipped a switch for me and
helped me develop more of a growth
mindset again helped me break away from
the line of thinking I'd been on that
I'd reached my full potential and
couldn't get any stronger so that was
winter of 2011 so that's when that's
when those ideas started finally taking
root in my mind again and so between
that winter and that spring I think
April or so I finally hit new PRS for
the first time in four and a half years
and they were little PRS it was a 565
squat which was a 15 pound all-time PR a
415 bench which was a 10 pound all time
PR and a 6 it was a 605 deadlift I've
done 600 even before so I pulled 605 and
that was a five-pound all time PR and
that's when the switch went from halfway
flipped - all the way flipped and I
realized I'm not my limit I can't
actually get stronger there's a very
liberating thought and that's when I
really just started training like a
madman in between that spring and that
August I went from those numbers to a
650 squat I benched 435 from the gym but
up for 19 at a meet and pulled 645 all
of which were big PRS that was at the
time a world-record total at 220
drug-tested and so that's when I that's
when that feeling of invincibility
really came back that I feel like had
been so important early on that I lost
along the way
so then between that summer and the next
spring May of 2013 I took those numbers
too
a 750 squat that was with wraps so it
wasn't actually a hundred pound PR
probably more like a 50 pound jump in
the squat a bench 445 in the gym got 425
426 something weird in kilos at the meet
and I pulled 725 in the gym and 710 at a
meet
so the 725 was an 80 pound jump on the
deadlift and the 710 at the meet was
relatively easy actually
but the world record at the time was in
1884 total so I was going to the meet
only to break the world record so I
needed 710 to hit 1885 to break it by
one pound so but yeah so just that
change in mindset took me from a mid
fives squat low fours bench low sixes
deadlift to a mid 7 squat mid 4s bench
and low sevens deadlift in about the
span of 14 15 months you know I tried
some different training programs during
the time I tried some different diet
protocols during the time but really the
only thing that was consistent all the
way through is that every time I went to
the gym I had gotten back to the mindset
where I expected to be stronger and then
since then since 2013 I got married that
summer which was great senior year of
college was hectic and then we moved to
California this summer and just moved
back so we've been moving around a lot
training hasn't been quite as consistent
but in spite of all of that I've still
been able to hit some more PRS I
squatted 750 for a double I've been for
75 reverse grip and finally hit 455 with
a normal grip and deadlift I haven't
really been training it that hard but I
was just a hair's breadth away from
locking out of 735 and I think I
strained it oblique but
the strength the strength is definitely
there so anyway that is basically my
entire training history and if if I want
you to extract one lesson out of that
it's that belief in yourself and what
you're capable of is just a very very
foundational factor for reaching your
potential and breaking past plateaus
when I was when I was training initially
and made those great gains during the
middle period when I was stalled for
three or four years and during this most
recent period when I've been breaking
records lifting heavy things
overall doing well you know I've tried
my diets have have run the gamut my
training programs have run the gamut the
strongest factor at least that I can
identify that has separated the two
periods on either end of rapid growth
from the period of stagnation in the
middle is just simply the belief in
myself that I could do more now
obviously I belief won't get you
everywhere
like it's it's not it doesn't give you
that much on its own obviously it
doesn't replace a good training and good
nutrition good recovery practices
sleeping enough etc etc but it is I
believe it's necessary if you're going
to reach your full potential so there
are two basic sets of limits you have
there are physical limits and there are
mental limits the thing about physical
limits is you really can't do anything
about them they're largely genetic some
people are simply bigger and stronger
than others or more responsive to
training than others and I mean until
robust gene therapies come out you can't
really you can't really do anything with
those however mental limits are very
much changeable they're very mutable
whereas the physical ones are immutable
so the physical limits are the ones who
really
can't do anything about and I'm assuming
when you're training what you're trying
to do is you want to reach your physical
limits you know whatever your potential
is you want to get there but the thing
about that is you don't know what your
physical limits are until you play the
hand you're dealt but bringing mental
limits into it you have to play the hand
you were dealt with the expectation that
it's a good one if you believe that you
were dealt a good hand and you expect to
make great progress there's a good
chance you will you may not be the best
but you will be the best that you can
possibly be if you are dealt a great
hand and you expect that it was a bad
one then even if your potential was here
if your mental limit is here you're not
getting past it your mental limit has to
be at your physical limit or above it
and this has been illustrated in
research the placebo effect is
absolutely wild to studies in particular
I find very interesting one was by
arielle in 1974 what they did basically
is for seven weeks they had people
training and they told them you know
train as hard as you can for seven weeks
those of you that make the best gains
will get an opportunity to take free
legal steroids for four weeks and will
study their effects so they were doing
squat bench press military press and I
think seated overhead press and during
the first seven weeks of training the
average strength gains across those four
lifts were ten kilos so 22 pounds in the
last four weeks when they thought they
were taking steroids but we're actually
just taking placebo pills they gained an
average of 45 kilos over over those same
four lifts which is right at a hundred
pounds so a hundred pounds instead of
twenty-two pounds in four weeks instead
of seven simply because their
expectations had changed nothing
physiological about them had changed
they weren't on steroids in either can
but when they thought they were on
steroids they thought they would make a
lot better strength gains and so they
were able to another interesting study
who was by Maggie Norris in 2000 and he
had he was a coach of a I think the
Great Britain powerlifting team and so
he had ten folks their average squats
and deadlifts and deadlifts were low
sixes average bench low force low to mid
force so these were strong guys and
basically the same set up they maxed one
week the next week he gave them placebo
pills and told them that they were a
fast-acting steroid and instantly their
maxes improved four to five percent so
roughly ten to fifteen kilos like ten to
fifteen kilo pr's on all lifts
immediately just because they thought
they were on a fast-acting steroid so
they trained for two more weeks
still thinking they were on these
steroids and at the end of those two
weeks they maxed again half of them
we're told that they'd been on a placebo
the whole time half of them were told
that they were still on steroids the
ones who thought they were still on
steroids were able to replicate those
numbers hold onto those 10 15 kilo PRS
the ones who found out they were on
placebos the whole time in spite of the
fact that they knew that they weren't on
steroids when they hit those PRS two
weeks prior were still unable to match
them and basically went back to baseline
again just illustrating how expectations
can very strongly affect outcomes so
just to boil this down what I'm saying
is this if you want to reach your full
potential you need to start looking at
the people who are the best and expect
that you can compete on their level that
may not be within your physical limits
but until you assume that you are
capable of doing that it's simply never
going to happen
you have to us you have to play the hand
you were dealt with the assumption
that it's good enough to reach that and
see the thing is if if you don't do that
if you assume you're playing a bad hand
then when you don't make much progress
it's a lot easier to stomach so when you
expect greatness you do open yourself up
for the possibility of failure and
disappointment but you have to be
willing to do that if you're going to
reach your long-term potential so that's
it guys thanks for watching please like
and subscribe if you're interested in
reading more a lot of this was based off
of an old article I wrote that'll be
linked in the description along with
another article I wrote about steroids
largely having to do with the placebo
effect if you're interested in reading
more about that so like I said like and
subscribe thanks for watching bye